these people
are systematically oppressed by their
own government
we've been waking up to horrific stories
every day
heartbreaking images separating mothers
from their children
they live in a police state where
they're monitored by one of the most
advanced and intrusive surveillance
systems in the world
imagine that the police force you to
stand in front of camera
for biometric data collection every
online activity
is tracked imagine that the police force
you to install
spying app on your phone their religion
is restricted
many traditional muslim names are even
banned for newborns
party officials are frequently attacking
islam
as very old-fashioned very backward
these are some of the suspected
detention camps where an estimated one
million
uyghurs are held many of them have not
been heard from
since being detained
yet is a uyghur rights activist he joins
me now from bahrain thanks so much for
your time
is this both that we're seeing from the
u.s really going to make any difference
to what's happening to weakest in china
and i know in the last as you said 20
years there's been a huge
you know government plan it's literally
think of the palestinians
and the european jews that came in in
the 1930s and 40s right think of that
now that's happening so what are the
latest statistics in terms of
uh the the broader population being just
camped in by the authorities and and put
in so from my understand you're
basically saying that the chinese
government doing this not necessarily
because they hate islam
but because they understand islam is
part of the kind of
social and spiritual dna of the yogurt
people
and they're just afraid that the yugo
people are going to become
self-governing they're going to have
they want to basically split away from
the chinese republic
are you saying that's the main fear of
the government perfect
you perfectly summed it up there the
women they were saying they
they ended up not having their periods
there is gang rape
regardless of men and women um even some
men have testified that they were
gang-raped by prison guards right now
it is estimated anywhere between 1
million to about 7 or 8 million people
in these camps
or have gone and left these camps these
camps um
whether it be the concentration camps
which mainly is for
torturing um indoctrinating
and creating chinese people because
one of the reasons why actually the main
reason why we go
in these camps is because we are not
chinese enough
we are not assimilated enough i've
spoken to some former concentration camp
detainees where they've told me that
they were taken um and they were
urinated upon
and you think urinated upon by chinese
gods and you know why they urinated upon
what one of these people is because they
said
don't you muslims wash yourself before
you pray
wash yourself with this
so the first phase is basically right
after she's done
her menses all right she she's basically
seeking the high
value male as angela always talks about
she's seeking that that man
who is the highest valued dominant male
that she can find
she is now seeking more security more
stability
because in the off chance that she is
pregnant you know through biology
the highest value male might not stick
around right so she needs that
that security that provided that
provisioning right so
in step two in phase two the the two you
know
last week's latter weeks of the month
for her cycle
she's now gonna you know find more uh
you know secure
stable predictable men attractive the
month so the birth control pills keep
them in this state
so what society planned parenthood
whatever you want to call it
they're they're going into this point
where they're forcing women
and incentivizing women to one become
single moms
but that's another issue but two uh take
these pills
you know so you can do whatever and not
have to take accountability for raising
a kid
but what these pills are doing is
they're feminizing
men and masculinizing women
how are they masculinizing women because
they keep women at that stage
in the luteal phase i believe in biology
and that basically makes
women find beta males more attractive
isn't that twisted isn't that messed up
that's that's going against the natural
fitra that brother gabriel talked about
and the second thing is that birth
control pill
that's coming out of her urine it's
going into the sewers there's clinical
scientific primary peer-reviewed
literature showing that this water
they're forming in biology they call
them secondary sex characteristics all
right
so they're not your genitalia which are
your your primary
but they're forming those things that
women have
and it's it's increasing the the
estrogen and progesterone of men
biological human males that are drinking
the water
that filtration systems today can't fill
so i basically categorize
men into three different states all
right so
the actually the first two aren't even
men i consider them boys but hear me out
so the first one is
we'll talk about it as level one
[Music]
because they both have truth to what
they're saying so they think
wholeheartedly they're true right
um but that's my point if you go in the
middle you'll see okay it sounds basic
but people don't actually think about it
in the moment there are bad women and
they're good women they're bad men and
they're good men
so khalas let's deal with the entire
issue of like society as a whole and how
it shapes these people
and in that balanced approach you'll
find proper ways of thinking
i really like uh you know you guys
mashallah you guys are this this is
podcast
it's just so natural you know it's so
organic you know it's like we're just
chilling and just talking you know it's
just i like it you know sometimes
certain things are so like
scripted like hey brother what do you
think brother
so yeah i like i like this very cool i
feel natural
i i definitely like what we talked about
so far in terms of the whole
uh feminist movement the whole gender
role switching
and we got women brainwashed here right
now currently to
to you know look at all these all these
helpful house husbands
who do you were talking about 50 of
chores yesterday gabriel
i'm talking about these women want men
to do all of them
and they're out here you know being a
man being a breadwinner
and i feel like this is something not
much talked about
lately but birth controls have a huge
role to do with this and for people that
have no idea what i'm talking about
basically a woman's you know not to go
on a tangent because it's all relevant
but
a woman's proliferative cycle right her
ovulatory cycle
how it works is she's divided into two
phases all right i'm going on this so
the first phase is basically right after
she's done
her menses all right she she's basically
seeking the high value male as angel
always talks about
she's seeking that that man who is the
highest
value dominant male that she can find
this is this is hard-wired into their
biology
and they don't care about anything else
they don't care about provider they
don't care about security they just want
that
why because it is in this time that
they're preparing for
ovulation when they can be pregnant so
it is in their best
interest by virtue of nature to secure
the highest value
offspring and you cannot secure the
highest value offspring if you cannot
secure the highest volume male
as soon as she gets pregnant and you
know even if she doesn't get pregnant
her body doesn't know she's
she's not pregnant until you know her
next period but as soon as she ovulates
as soon as that
that thing has happened she is now
seeking more security more stability
because in the off chance that she is
pregnant you know through biology
the highest value male might not stick
around right so she needs that
that security that provided that
provisioning right so
in step two in phase two the the two you
know
last week's latter weeks of the month
for her cycle
she's now gonna you know find more uh
you know
secure stable predictable men attractive
and you know in the there's a lot of
different ways to coin these terms you
know
some people say beta some people say you
know weak some people say more emotional
whatever
but they will find this man more
attractive than
the bad boy that they were chasing in
the first two weeks
all right so when women say oh i want a
nice guy they're not wrong and when
women say
i want a bad boy they're not wrong it's
just you're not knowing what time of the
month they're
on anyway my point is birth control
pills keep women in the the phase of
their cycle
at week three and four of the cycle so
basically when they're
they're seeking that predictable
provider type that provisional type that
that guy who's you know he doesn't look
the best but he has 200 000 in the bank
you know he has 100 000 coming in every
year they seek this
man ladies and gentlemen when they
are on birth control pills and when
they're on this time of the month so the
birth control pills keep them in this
state
so what society planned parenthood
whatever you want to call it
they're they're they're going into this
point where they're forcing women
and incentivizing women to one become
single moms
but that's another issue but two uh take
these pills
you know so you can do whatever and not
have to take accountability for raising
a kid
but what these pills are doing is
they're feminizing men
and masculinizing women how are they
masculinizing women
because they keep women at that stage in
the luteal phase i believe in biology
and that basically makes women find beta
males more attractive
isn't that twisted isn't that messed up
that's that's going against the natural
fitra that brother gabriel talked about
and the second thing is that birth
control pill
that's coming out of her urine it's
going into the sewers there's clinical
scientific primary peer-reviewed
literature showing that this water
is literally they they have fish right
they have male fish who have
uh whatever chromosomes they have it's
not xy like males but
they're basically turning into
hermaphrodites and they're basically
forming
they're forming in biology they call
them secondary sex characteristics all
right
so they're not your genitalia which are
your primary
but they're forming those things that
women have and
it's it's increasing the the estrogen
and progesterone of men
biological human males that are drinking
the water
that filtration systems today can't fill
so uh it goes much deeper than us
just thinking you know this is
propaganda and us pulling things out of
thin air
i just wanted to put that out there
right that's
100 that's why you find them you know i
mean
people keep talking about uh you know uh
like okay people were not coming out
before in history
right but i think things didn't exist
as they do today and a lot of the
changes that you see
in the biology of human beings being
male females is because of the nutrition
because of the pollution because of what
we're taking
because of what women are taking men are
taking how it gets back into the
environment
how it gets uptaken again and it's
changing the way
we we are no doubt we are um
corrupting our fitra we are corrupting
our fitra
on all levels and yes you're having all
these new
type of you know it's like
um i know you need a new label almost
every
every year to define what's going on or
what's happening within
human biology right so yes these are
challenges that have not
you know they're unprecedented i mean
before yes homosexuality existed
yes it was a perversion yes lesbianism
existed yes
throughout you know the history of
mankind you know
and so on but what we're dealt what
we're dealing with today
because of the corruption of our
environment of
you know nutrition of just society
what's happening on all levels
you're faced with uh so many things you
know every action has a reaction
as you said women taking
uh these these pills you know these
contraceptives
changes women they're the way they eat
just just let's cultural
cultural influences biological
influences
both of them contribute to our makeup
okay the total past learning history it
is a
joint uh collaboration between the
physical
the emotional the spiritual the
intellectual
so just just observational
okay just look at women today
look at men today okay go to the mall i
don't know wherever you can take a
sample population
look at the way women walk look at the
way women talk look at the way women
dress how
masculinized it is you know hey buddy
what's up man
yeah you know there's no softness
anymore there's no
uh you know there's no femininity
anymore you know the way they dress the
way they talk the way they
carry themselves there's no affair
there's no you know chastity there's no
it's not society doesn't reward a
a a humble or
uh what's the word i'm looking for the
feminine girl man society shame yeah
exactly right for what is this you know
you're gonna be you know you're gonna be
used as this and that
i mean that that um humbleness that that
modesty is not there anymore right that
we used to be attractive you know and
now no you have to be the
biggest baddest girl talking about weird
stuff
and and that's when you're like wow this
is what a woman really is i mean that's
disgusting you know
and men are confused
we have this weird phenomenon in the
arab world right now
where men are are
chasing these these feminine boys or
these feminine men because they find
more feminine traits in them as opposed
to the women
which is very i've experienced this as a
teacher there
and as a principal i know people are
going to go crazy about us but
like you know the men were chasing these
asian
filipino boys you know who are working
in those countries because they're more
feminine
than the women that are around who are
being now pushed to work getting
high salaries to be pushed to go outside
and to do the work right so they're now
stimulated
to be out there they're not feminine
anymore i mean they might be putting
you know they think that i'm feminine if
i'm gonna look like a genetically
modified barbie and i'll put
tons of makeup on and look like you know
god horrible right
that's how they that's how they manifest
their femininity you know
big deep voice and you know crazy makeup
on and then they think that that's
feminine you know
no man it's hard are you talking about
oh no bro bro bro in the middle east
there's a lot of ladyboys bro they
they they get brought on purpose it's by
order you know in the middle east
there's a lot of ladyboys
especially in male salons okay cutting
hair
and so on it's become a culture there
they only
hire these kind of you know ladyboys and
the men chased them like crazy
because they're so feminine they're so
like taking care of themselves and so
you know
so you know whatever and and guys chase
this stuff man you know so they're
confused disgusting
and if i ask i used to ask bro he's not
i used to that's not wrong it's reality
i used to ask my students bro imagine
bro imagine imagine i
i had a grade 12 i was teaching grade 12
english
class of 24. two boys come to me and
they're like teacher look you got to
address this issue
and i said what's the problem he said 22
so out of 24 only two of us are straight
the other ones are all chasing these
little boys you know it was like
i was like are you sure he's like yeah
he's like it's just the culture and they
explain it to me you know
and i said but you guys are muslim you
guys know it he said no they're not
gay they they don't but he says that
they feel that those are like very girly
they're very
attractive because they're very feminine
and i was like i was trying to wrap my
hat around
you know i did some research looked at
it opened my eyes a bit more
and i was like makes sense you know what
i mean i understand what's going on
right now
you know it's disgusting yeah but but
you see
the imbalance you know it's like women
are becoming more masculine
the fit of the man wants something
feminine uh some of them are becoming
feminine because
women are too masculine it's like just
pin palming back and forth and then
everyone gets messed up you know
so it's just it's a big problem but
you're right man
this this whole thing uh you know it's
it's propagated by
you know getting curved or doing you
know when angel talks about you were
done dirty
in your childhood or in your life and
you are now
trying to project that onto other people
and you're just walking around this chip
in your shoulder so
i basically categorized men into three
different states all right so
the actually the first two aren't even
men i consider them boys but hear me out
so the first one
is we'll talk about it as level one so
when you're in level one
you're basically conditioned by society
all right you're basically a yes man
you do what everyone says you never put
yourself or allah first you put everyone
else first
you put these jahos first you just
you're just bending over backwards for
everyone
um and just like uh brother gabriel
talked about in our last podcast
how you kind of have like when you take
the red pill and you finally like learn
about the truth
it's basically who you are before that
all right so level one you're basically
just a product of society
um here you're basically doing
everything for everyone you're over
you're over jumping to people's uh whims
and to the demands because you feel like
if you don't
people won't value you you feel like
your only value is
just doing everything for everyone else
and this could be for your woman this
could be for your boss
you feel like if you don't do anything
you know aside from 110 percent
they will not value they will leave you
they will replace you so
you huh yeah basically a little bit
basically a sim and then you take this
this understanding that gabriel brother
gabriel was talking about
of you finally understand everything
you've been conditioned and programmed
was a lie
and when you realize this then you
realize okay damn like
that means i can't give anything i can't
give my woman any type of
attention i can't listen to any of my
boss's demands
i can't be nice to anyone or be kind or
be you know kind of like the the
prophets kind of just
like like all of the prophets we've had
just genuine
kind and and valuable people i can't do
any of that
um you know level two people and men
their
their whole predisposition is if i give
even one percent
they'll think i'm weak they'll i'll be
taken for granted
so now i gotta now be toxic i gotta now
be
you know violent and oppressive i gotta
now not share my feelings i gotta
just basically hide who i am and level
two is the douche
level two is the group so so when you
talk about level one it's kind of like
the beta male and whatever
level two is kind of like that bad boys
girls chase you know that dog
that that street guy that guy in a gang
but he has the dominant traits that you
find attractive
which level three has also but i'm gonna
get to that but he's not
grounded in uh abundance see
level one has a scarcity mentality
because he feels like if he doesn't give
everything
they'll leave me behind level two still
has scarcity because they think if i
don't give everything
if i give even anything then they're
gonna take advantage of me so i can't
give anything i gotta
you know be like this i gotta walk like
this i gotta now appear you know more
chad or more dumb than i am and i can't
really show them who i am
and you know i gotta now you know cut
everyone off and act like i'm
going through a lot and whatever these
men do bro that i've seen uh people call
it red pill rage
but you got what i mean and level two
did still scarcity
level three is when you realize bro
you don't have to play all these games
you don't have to pretend to be any of
these you know
these aforementioned bubbles you could
be you when you validate people when you
do things for them it's because you
wanted to do it not because they made
you do it and not because you felt like
if you weren't gonna do it
you're gonna be taken advantage of or
you know vulnerable or
you know invalidated you you think for
yourself
you live for yourself you compliment
people when you want to compliment
people you don't do it because you feel
like if you don't they're gonna you know
find someone else who does but you also
don't hide your compliments because you
feel like if you do they're gonna think
you're soft and weak
you know you truly stop caring about
this dunya and you focus on what matters
you have purpose like i know said
see level three is what women will find
more attractive than
this this bad boy that's thug level two
energy
but the reason you know people don't
talk about it is because this man
doesn't exist anymore bro
most men today i would say 90 of men are
level one
all right this is why they're tired of
it and they're i'd say nine percent of
men
are level two and like one percent of
men are level three
but it doesn't even matter it's one
percent because if it's one percent
most of those men are taken bro and even
if they're muslim men they probably have
four wives so
their you know tryouts are kind of
canceled this season so they got no
slots open
so regardless of what you want to say
that one percent man isn't even one
percent it's like 0.1
you know what i mean so yeah women at
the end of the day they got to realize
that
you know and women are realizing this
too just like you're saying they're
waking up they're realizing you know
this man that society told us i should
be attracted
to i'm not you know prince charming or
this white knight i'm not really
attracted to him and
you know you got you got this whole
issue about nikkah
and marriage and wally syndrome that i
know you talked about with your series
with abu american
it's crazy because you got you got
parents that have
want the best for their children want
the best for the girls they
force them to marry this guy who's
probably bald you know
out of shape you know doesn't take care
of his hygiene doesn't take care of his
appearance but
he's uh he's a lawyer or an engineer or
a physician
bringing in like 250k a year and they
force them to be married and now the
woman's like damn i'm really not
you know attracted to this guy but
cheating is haram doing this around but
it's like
how long can she go without breaking you
know so she realized this is not the man
that i want
so after that she's like okay cool
that level two guy that bad boy that guy
who's exciting
or you know mysterious like i don't know
much about him they go for this guy but
they realize they can never form that
emotional connection with this man
because this man is still in scarcity
he's not opening up he's not vulnerable
so they're out here like okay i wanna i
wanna form you know connection with this
guy
but i can't or in the in the terms we
talked about before
only two out of four weeks of the month
i'm attracted to this guy and the other
two i'm like damn i don't really
really know who he is you know so this
is when you know
they get done dirty by this guy where
i'm going with this is
they get curved by this guy or they get
their time wasted they get
done dirty like anno says and now they
walk around with this chip in their
shoulder like oh men are trash men are
dogs
they talk to other girls that are young
like oh don't go for this guy go for the
predictable guy go for the stable guy
you know
and they don't realize it but the girls
they're talking to they themselves are
finding those
waste man's attractive but they can't do
anything about it
that's why women always love giving
girls advice
but they can't take it when it comes to
themselves sorry to say ladies i'm
talking about women on average not every
woman
before you know the select two feminists
we got comment on that
but if you could find yourself a man
ladies that
is truly on his purpose he has emotional
intelligence like he is not afraid to
open up
he can fully be you know loving you but
at any given time he can leave you like
he doesn't need you
keep that guy because what he needs his
priority
is allah it's his purpose it's his it's
his role in this dunya it's not you
and it's not you know what society wants
him
wants him to have has his purpose and
for men
i feel like you all got to find women
even though the numbers are declining
today
more faster than not than ever before
you got to find women simply put that
are okay being women
they don't think of it like some ego
battle like oh if i'm a woman
damn like what's what society you're
gonna say like you gotta find a woman
who worked through that programming that
her mom taught her
i worked through the program and her
friend started that society taught her
that feminism taught her
and she's okay being a woman you feel me
so
it goes both ways but i agree with
brother gabriel 1000
of the way that until men fix themselves
women will not fix themselves all right
because they depend on you
and the wonderful point i want brother
gabriel to go into right now
to drive my point home all the way is he
made a video about
this this whole convert craze and this
whole revert thing where
women are going after uh you know men
that are new rivers and men
are going after uh women that are
rebirths but it only works
one time one way right more times than
not and i want you to go
go into that because i feel like it'll
definitely drive my point home
yeah no doubt no doubt um
see everyone's i think
the concept of attraction and connection
is is something that a lot of people
don't are not honest about it like both
men and women i think i think guys are a
bit more honest than than women
because we you know i think
it's so simple you know and i always
tell sisters sisters just
just wake up a little bit and you can be
the happiest woman in the world because
you're gonna make your husband happy
actually it's not that difficult to make
us happy we men
don't don't require so
much you know we're very simple you know
we want as you said allah first
okay that's our purpose in life when we
find that then we are driven
we have a drive hamdillah okay means
we're moving we're moving movement is
barakah movement is good
alhamdulillah you know so don't stop
that you got sisters saying oh don't go
to the masjid brothers stay with me
why are you going dawa why are you oh
you know you have to
it's like no men are not
men are not made to sit in the house the
faster sisters understand that and the
faster they facilitate for men
to be outside be their job and whatever
not piss them off
and why didn't you come at you know five
and you know you're late two minutes and
stuff like that
i'm not saying that you know you set
your wife up and you know you're late
two hours and whatnot stay to stick
true to your word because that is the
sun of the process but what i'm saying
is that
the faster women understand the way we
work they'll be happy man
because it's so simple to satisfy us let
us fulfill our purpose
okay number one respect us number two we
need
respect okay when we come home our
children
everything you can facilitate that we
expect that from you as the woman
if you don't do it forget about i get
respect at work and it's not it doesn't
really matter
if i walk in my house and my woman don't
respect me that's gonna kill me man
we don't like that okay number three
very simple intimacy we we we need
love men need love okay we are have been
built like that we've been nurtured by
our mothers
we need that that's a driving force for
us okay
call it sex call it whatever we need
that's how we express our love
our love we express it through making
love okay if you reject us
women don't understand what happens to
men when they get rejected
we it it kills us especially the woman
that we care about that we committed to
if she tells you no she rejects you
that's why the process was so
strict about what happens if a woman
rejects her husband
don't reject us respect us don't reject
us give us love
you know and and and i don't know we're
we're good that's it
that's it that's it other stuff details
here and there to fill it
that's pretty much it man you miss
let me just you miss food bro you miss
good food
yeah but like like like like uh you know
we can still move on without like
good food like hamdullah you know a
woman will try and she'll cook something
and you know
you know you're like blah you know and
then that's what the process said you
know you can lie to your wife you know
she's gonna say
honey how was that you know and you're
like amazing
you know there was a there was a hadith
of someone where uh i think it was
men and women who were married a woman's
cursed
if she you know rejects a man uh until
what the next morning or something like
that
well the next morning as the angels
right so and not just that
you know i mean it went even more in
extreme it's like if you are
riding a camel and i feel the urge of
being
intimate i call it making love because
you know sex and f and this and that is
like it's become so dirty by the western
even though yes you can have a lot of
fun in it you know and
go crazy but like the process also said
in the hadith
even if you're on the back of a camel
man like
i don't want you guys to make too many
uh you have to think too much about them
but
i mean you understand it's like
you know it's like it's he says even if
you're cooking
your top of the stove and you're cooking
and it's about to like you know
the food is about to burn if he calls
you you go why
why why why why you know rasulullah and
put such an emphasis
because we will psychologically
suffer in the back of our mind that
rejection
equals to disrespect equals to a lack of
worth
the woman who's supposed to be the one
that's
taking got your back is telling you no
and and you know guess what a man is
going to do
no once no twice we play baseball no
three times turn the other way and start
looking around for other options man
see here's the thing and it's dark we
got a ton of women that are gonna shine
we got a ton of women that are gonna
address gabriel's point and say oh
that's fragile masculinity or
whatever but bro simply put men don't
care about love and attention we want
respect
all right but conversely women want love
and attention women want to be loved and
and have attention more than they get
respect there was a study done where
there were a couple wives you know in
one cohort they they got more
respect than attention they earned more
money than their man or
their men basically thought of them as
higher status and gave more respect
and then there was another group where
you know their men gave their wives more
love devotion attention but
not as much respect as their love and
more people got divorces in the first
group than the second
and i think the opposite vice versa is
is going to be completely true too
if a woman gives you love but she
doesn't give you respect nah i i need my
women to
to you know hundred and ten thousand
percent
respect me and love me but respect me a
little more than she loves me
or if she loves me more than she
respects me there's no
there's no like there's not that full
submission for
her subscribing to my program there's no
she's not on the same page you feel me
and if we were to apply the three models
that you said
you got the sword boy you got the douche
and you got the gentle warlord
bro like if a guy is in the third stage
if a guy is being a gentle warlord like
he pretty much makes the woman be in her
feminine
and just think just think for a second
what woman would not want to
be intimate and make love with a level 3
man no doubt but what woman
will question and tell the guy no
when the guy's at level one or level two
that's true max 100 man and you see you
see these uh
and i know you know we already made an
episode on pornography but
you know we got bro they're coming out
with weird porn plots and stuff like
that like
you know we got women that have these
types of you know
fantasies yeah women have fantasies but
you know some of the things they're
portraying they're not real
so the three levels that we talked about
the anger coined perfectly he put a name
to the face
as the the soy boy the douche and the
gentle warlord
if a woman's with a level one man this
is called the the
the would you say the the soy boy soyboy
the problem we're fantasizing about
level three
well she's doing it with level one
that's the thing see but most women
don't even know level three so
don't get me started with female sexual
psychology bro oh man
so yeah we need an episode on that
i know man if they're with a level one
boy
who's a soy boy they will cheat on on
him with almost anyone that's
that's more attractive and the reason
being is because
bro he's he's he's a sword but he
doesn't he doesn't there's no
desire there's no dynamic he's more
feminine than her
almost you know all the time so that
that's the thing if
if you you know get cheated on more
times than not i'm talking most of the
men that get cheated on they're probably
level one
level two she's not gonna cheat on you
as much
because you're already you already do it
for her you're probably the guy she
cheats on
uh her man with so with level two she's
not gonna cheat on you
more times than not but these are the
type of women that like uh
um if their man gets locked up you know
okay then
cool i need some attention he was there
for me or when
there's a lot of porn plots that are you
know there's like the the woman who
cheats on her man
with the pool boy when her man's at work
this is that this is that woman because
the man yeah he does it for her but he's
not there emotionally
and she won't cheat on him uh physically
first she'll cheat on him emotionally
but emotional obviously we know it turns
into physicality that's why like bro
no male friends like that's rule number
one for any woman
at least if you want to make things work
but that's with level two
level three though nah bro she's
probably not cheating on me unless she's
like drugged and raped or something like
that like
level three if she's with a man that's
level three bro
i've heard of women that their men were
locked up and they're still keeping it
you know
they're staying loyal they're staying
faithful these are the men that
they they fully have that bond with him
it's unseverable
and allah has ordained for us to have a
wonderful
diametrically opposed polar opposite
type of wonderful cultivated
relationship with women
and vice versa but you can't you know
adopt society's programming and try to
be a woman so you can relate to a woman
you know what i mean like no disrespect
to because you know we'll talk about
lgbt gay guys i'm not putting them down
but
all the guys i knew that were that were
gay
[Laughter]
you see all the gay guys i knew in high
school growing up
most of the people they had walking
around it was always women they didn't
have male friends because they could
relate to women
on a cellular level because it is
biochemical right
um in terms of men that were in their
natural
fitra in their natural positioning
they're not gonna be
like what level two does see level two
is like oh i gotta you know wield ten
different chicks
and act like a bad boy to get more
chicks and i gotta look like i got women
you feel me nah level three this is the
type of guy that
that's he's he's looked up by men and
there's a book uh
i think it was by jack donovan it's
called the way of men
and angel recommended it to me and he he
talks about how
as a man you're not your values not
equated my guy
to how much women you get a man's value
is equated to how other men see him and
where he falls in that hierarchy
yo and pause before any of y'all
continue um
reframing of the the three categories
here
you got the soy boy you got the douche
and y'all got daddy
much better
we're going to make a whole whole
how to be a complete man and i want you
guys to you know let us down in the
comments below brother gabriel is
welcome anytime in our podcast but
what other perfect guesses than him and
i feel like when we do do that podcast
in the future inshallah
we're not going to just talk about just
finances we're not going to talk about
just health and you know bodybuilding
and working out and strength training
we're going to talk about everything
having your man in check
just being a complete man at the end of
the day and
i think once we can do it we can do uh
three three of you and uh myself and
above america and that's gonna be like a
killer
i was just thinking about that that's i
know
that's gonna change the world yeah it's
a popular world war bro
i feel like a topic talked of not talked
about enough is emotional intelligence
um so we are definitely going to include
that in that video if not we're going to
include a separate video
just on that but i think this was a
solid podcast
i have nothing else to say if you guys
want to take it away you guys can see
i have to get moving as well i have
another interview at nine gotta get
ready inshallah
man oh no bro you didn't close it off
last episode why don't you close it out
all right all right
guys thank you for watching we had the
wonderful brother gabriel and we had
obviously fired me and
romney he's non-existent but rami um i
hope you enjoyed it hope
it helped in one way shape or form
considering hopping on brother gabriel's
channel links will be yes
go into his channel go watch his videos
and read this man's book because we're
all going to read it
and we're going to talk about it and all
that and sure 100 man we're going to
we're going to do a review not in the
sense that we rate it but we talk about
it that's okay value that you can get
without you know spoilers because
you all better hop on the man there's no
matter yes sir
with that being said guys like the video
share the video
see you guys next time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm